Traduttore: Barbara Barbier
Revisore: monica millefanti
L'estate del 2003
fu un'estate caldissima.
Mio figlio Emanuele aveva 6 anni,
era un bambino,
e noi abbiamo un piccolo stagno,
nel giardino di casa,
con i pesciolini rossi,
e viene da me con le lacrime agli occhi,
mi dice: "Papà, corri!"
Gli dico:
"Cosa è successo? Ti sei fatto male?"
"No, corri, c'è un pesciolino rosso
che sta morendo!"
Allora mi reco con lui allo stagno,
vedo che il suo pesciolino rosso preferito
stava morendo.
Lo avevamo comprato
un paio di settimane prima.
Studio un po' la situazione.
Gli dico:
"Emanuele, qui ormai è spacciato."
Lui dice: "Ma no, papà, è ancora vivo!"
Allora ci penso un po', gli dico:
"Mah, portiamolo magari al fiume."
Abbiamo un fiume vicino a casa.
Abitiamo a Gavardo,
vicino al Lago di Garda, vicino a Salò.
"Magari nel fiume riprende nuova vita."
E lui non voleva, perché sapeva che
l'avrebbe perduto per sempre nel fiume
Però ci pensa e dopo un po' mi dice:
"Dài, liberiamolo"
Allora prendiamo
abbiamo messo dentro l'acqua,
il pesciolino,
e l'abbiamo portato al fiume,
che dista 200 metri da casa nostra.
Lì scendiamo le scalette, c'è un bel parco dove portavo Emanuele da piccolo
a giocare.
Lui si avvicina, io in parte ansioso,
perché temevo la mia soluzione.
Lui lancia il pesciolino
e questo, misteriosamente, entra
nell'acqua e si mette a nuotare felice.
Io felicissimo.
Sai, papà genio, davanti al figlio.
Ma non faccio in tempo a gongolare
che parte un'anatra dall'altra parte
e si mangia il pesciolino al volo.
Tra l'altro mi ricordo la scena,
non l'ha ingoiato subito.
Lo teneva nel becco,
mentre lo portava via,
e Emanuele diceva
le parolacce alla papera,
diceva: "Bastarda!"
Poi si volta verso di me per trovare un
po' di consolazione, di conforto.
Io ero lì che mi sbudellavo dalle risate,
allora mi dava i pugni.
"Papà, perché ridi?"
Figurati, un bambino di sei anni
con il suo pesciolino.
Ma passano dieci anni.
E sono le tre di notte.
È il 24 novembre 2013.
Io mi trovo in piedi,
davanti allo stesso punto,
allo stesso fiume.
Accanto a me c'è un ragazzo,
di diciotto anni circa,
che ho appena conosciuto,
che si chiama Chris,
che mi ha appena detto
che mio figlio Emanuele
si è buttato vestito un'ora prima, lì,
dove aveva buttato il suo pesciolino.
E io sto seriamente prendendo
in considerazione l'idea
di seguirlo, di lanciarmi anch'io.
Ma qualcosa mi ha trattenuto.
Nella mia mente
è passata
tutta la mia vita.
Mi sono ricordato
di quando avevo tredici anni,
quando mio papà mi diede una tuta.
Questo è mio papà, io sono
alla vostra destra col cappellino.
Mi diede una tuta, che
si chiamava Pierrot,
e mi disse: "Dovrebbe andarti bene",
e mi insegnò a lavorare alla motrice.
La motrice è una macchina
dove c'è una spazzola sopra
e tu con il ginocchio devi
calcare contro tipo scolapaste,
tipo vassoi,
e tu ti specchiavi dentro questi prodotti
bellissimi e ti vedevi tutto nero
e la cosa che odiavo di più era
quando, la sera, mi lavavo,
facevo la doccia,
mi restava sempre il nero dentro negli
occhi, proprio come un Pierrot,
mi veniva la rabbia.
Un giorno, quando avevo 13 anni,
proprio i primi prodotti che lavoravo
erano i salini, i tappi dei salini,
sono dei piccoli prodotti di acciaio,
e mentre stavo lavorando
entra nell'officina di mio papà,
una piccola officinetta tutta nera,
un signore, tutto ben vestito, con
la giacca e la cravatta.
Gli guardavo le unghie belle pulite,
si è messo lì da parte, mi guardava.
Io lo guardo, ad un certo punto comincio
ad aumentare la velocità,
sempre di più. Volevo far vedere che ero
figo, che ero bravo, ovviamente.
Veloce, veloce, veloce,
cominciavo a sudare.
Lui guardava l'orologio
ogni tanto poi mi guardava,
poi guarda l'orologio poi guardava.
Guardava l'orologio,
si vede che deve andare via;
e in effetti dopo un po' va via,
va da mio papà.
Poi mio papà mi chiama
e quella volta fu la prima volta che presi
un calcio nel sedere da mio papà:
perché quel signore era il nostro cliente
mi pagava a cottimo, un tanto a pezzo
quindi aveva detto che lavoravamo
troppi pezzi all'ora,
ha dimezzato i prezzi a mio papà.
Pensate!
Questa cosa mi ha insegnato che nella
vita dobbiamo sempre guardare le cose
da almeno due prospettive diverse.
Perché è così.
E poi, a sedici anni, io avevo un sogno.
Volevo diventare ricco, volevo
guadagnare un sacco di soldi
e fare esperienza
perché, prima di tutto,
non volevo fare questo lavoro
e non avrei mai voluto che i miei figli
facessero quel lavoro.
Però volevo anche aiutare gli altri.
Sapevo che sul danaro si basava tutto.
Se io avessi avuto i soldi,
chissà quanti bambini potevo aiutare.
Vedevo le foto di quei bambini che
provenivano dall'Africa,
con le pance gonfie.
Mi dicevo "potevi essere uno di loro".
E allora ho studiato, ho fatto il liceo
scientifico, poi ho fatto l'università.
Mentre studiavo aiutavo mio papà.
Registravo la lezione, me la riascoltavo con le
cuffiette mentre lavoravo alla motrice,
durante il giorno.
E così mi laureo, 30 anni fa esatti,
in questi giorni,
mi laureavo in economia e commercio.
Immaginate questi pensieri
che attraversano la mia mente come il
fotogramma della mia vita,
mentre guardo l'acqua.
Laureato, mi vedo giovane laureato
con la voglia di cambiare il mondo,
con la voglia di dire la mia.
Vado a lavorare in un'azienda poi
nell'89 mi sposo.
Avrò tre figli meravigliosi:
Alessandra, Emanuele, Giulia.
Tra l'89 e il '93 comincia
a crescere la mia carriera;
divento responsabile amministrativo di
un'azienda, cominciano ad arrivare
i primi stipendi interessanti
ma niente rispetto a quello
che sarebbe successo dopo.
Vado a lavorare in un gruppo industriale
che ha progetti molto ambiziosi.
Divento amministratore delegato di
numerose società del gruppo,
mi occupo del reperimento
delle risorse finanziarie,
convinco un gruppo di banche
a darci finanziamenti enormi.
Facciamo un'OPA, la prima OPA della legge Draghi
su n'azienda quotata alla borsa di Milano.
La compriamo come gruppo.
Divento amministratore
delegato di quell'azienda.
Nel 99
creo un'azienda, una '.com',
di cui divento Presidente,
da quotare in borsa.
Arrivano i fondi,
arrivano i soldi, quelli veri.
Nel frattempo mi ero comprato una villa,
due ville, tre ville, quattro ville;
volevo sempre di più, di più, di più.
Le banche, visto che avevo patrimonio,
mi mettevano a disposizione altre linee di credito
perché scopri che quando hai soldi,
te ne offrono altri.
Quando non li hai, ti danno due dita
negli occhi, ovviamente.
E tu, cosa facevi?
Riempivi la linea di credito,
compravi le azioni con i tuoi soldi,
con i soldi che le banche ti davano.
Volevi sempre di più,
diventare sempre più ricco.
Ma poco alla volta mi stavo perdendo,
mi stavo trasformando
in quel Pierrot,
mi stavo davvero perdendo.
Finché arriva un giorno,
l'11 settembre 2001.
Crollano le Torri Gemelle.
Crollano tutte le borse.
In un solo giorno perdo
tutto quello che avevo.
Quello che pensava di essere
il più bravo, era in ginocchio.
E quello è stato un colpo duro, pesante,
per il quale molti dei miei conoscenti,
in quegli anni,
si sono tolti la vita.
Chi non si è più rialzato.
Ma io ho un motto
che è "Estote parati",
che significa "Siate preparati".
Mi son detto:"Qualsiasi cosa ti accadrà
nella vita dovrai
sempre combattere con dignità".
Mai mollare, mi dicevo, "never give up".
Mai mollare.
Ho combattuto mille battaglie
perché volevo rifarmi un'azienda.
Sì, qualcosa mi son rimesso un po'
in piedi, senza grandi splendori.
Mille battaglie, ma ho
combattute le battaglie sbagliate.
Perché quante volte sei arrivato a casa a
mezzanotte che i tuoi figli già dormivano.
Quante volte sei arrivato a casa,
sì, più presto;
ti chiedevano:
"Papà, facciamo la lotta sul tappeto?".
Gli dicevi no,
oggi sono stanco, sono stressato.
Oppure, su di loro scaricavi la tua rabbia,
solo per una giornata andata male,
per piccole cose, per cose banali.
Sì, ho combattuto davvero
le battaglie sbagliate.
È vero che mi sono rimesso
un po' in piedi, ma poi
l'ego che mi aveva ripreso è
tornato alla carica,
perché poi si prende
la tua vita personale.
Arriva un giorno, il 22 settembre del 2012
vado da mia moglie,
dopo 33 anni che eravamo assieme
dopo tre figli meravigliosi, le dico:
"Non ti amo più, me ne vado".
E me ne sono andato altrove.
Volevo smettere di combattere,
forse volevo cercare la scorciatoia.
E mi sono accorto presto
di aver fatto una grossa cavolata
e confessai a mia moglie
che sarei tornato.
Le dissi: "Tornerò."
E avevo deciso di tornare per la notte di
Natale, per il 24 dicembre, del 2013.
Quello era il momento giusto.
Ritrovare mia moglie,
la mia famiglia, a Natale.
Ma quella notte...
Quella notte mi trovavo
in piedi davanti a questo fiume,
mentre questo ragazzo era accanto a me.
Mancava ancora un mese a Natale,
era il 24 novembre.
Questo ragazzo
mi aveva appena raccontato
che Manuele era andato ad una festa con alcuni ragazzi più grandi di lui,
amici maggiorenni,
ragazzi di 19, 20, 21 anni.
A quella festa è girato di tutto,
alcol, marjuana, droghe sintetiche,
e Manuele aveva 16 anni,
ha provato quella robaccia.
Lo hanno accompagnato a casa.
E quando è arrivato sulla soglia di casa,
gli dicono gli amici:
"Vai a fare un giro al fiume, vai a
prendere un po' d'aria, così ti riprendi."
E quando è arrivato lì, davanti al punto
in cui aveva lanciato il suo pesciolino,
al compagno Chris gli dice:
"Io devo uccidermi."
L'amico tenta di trattenerlo e
lui s'è buttato.
S'è buttato in quel fiume.
Mentre guardavo il fiume,
e questo è il mio Emanuele,
avevo nei miei occhi i suoi occhi.
Mi ricordavo che proprio il giorno prima
ero andato a casa, l'avevo
visto più serio del solito.
Gli avevo detto: "Manuele, ti vedo serio.
Dobbiamo parlarci io e te."
Però poi guardando l'orologio,
che adesso non porto più,
gli avevo detto:
"Oggi non ho tempo per fermarmi
ci risentiamo domani,
perché devo sbrigare delle faccende."
E domani, era troppo tardi.
Ma qualcosa mi ha trattenuto.
Mi ricordavo di quanto Emanuele
fosse un ragazzo meraviglioso.
Sì, è vero che ha fatto
una grossa cavolata
ma lui era molto migliore di me.
Emanuele non sapeva odiare,
non sapeva tenere rancore,
e io a volte approfittavo di lui,
quando lo rimproveravo
non gli parlavo assieme
per tutto il giorno,
perché sapevo
che questo gli faceva male.
Volevo piegarlo.
E la sera sapevo che veniva da me,
bussava alla mia porta
e, con le lacrime agli occhi, mi diceva:
"Papà, scusami."
Voleva abbracciarmi.
Io non gli ho mai chiesto scusa.
E' per quello che non mi sono buttato.
Perché voglio assomigliare a lui.
Voglio perdere tutte quelle cose sbagliate
che si erano radicate dentro di me,
come padre, come uomo.
Qualche giorno prima mi aveva detto:
"Papà, io non ho 16 anni, tu non ne hai 50.
Dico: "Come?"
"Sì, se ci pensi noi siamo vecchissimi,
noi siamo...
Abbiamo più di un miliardo di anni
perché noi siamo l'evoluzione
di quella cellula primordiale
che oltre un miliardo di anni
fa ha originato la vita sulla terra,
i primi organismi monocellulari.
Questa cellula si è evoluta,
si è trasformata
ed è arrivata fino a noi.
Noi abbiamo un miliardo di anni.
È incredibile."
L'hanno trovato dieci ore dopo.
Annegato.
Lo hanno trovato così.
Forse, aveva teso la mano
per cercare il suo papà.
Che non c'era.
E sono tornato a casa. Sono tornato da
mia moglie, dalle mie figlie.
Anche se i primi giorni questo dolore
mi stava schiacciando.
I sensi di colpa per non essere stato
lì a tendergli la mano,
i sensi di colpa per non essermi
fermato il giorno prima.
i sensi di colpa per non essere
tornato a casa in tempo,
per non essermi buttato con lui,
in quel fiume.
Ma dopo solo due giorni,
nel momento più difficile,
in cui la follia mi stava prendendo,
Emanuele è venuto a salvarmi,
per la seconda volta.
È entrato dentro in un mio sogno.
Ho sognato che mi immergevo in quel fiume,
lo cercavo e non lo trovavo.
Ad un certo punto l'ho trovato,
in fondo al mare.
L'ho preso, l'ho tirato fuori dall'acqua,
ha aperto gli occhi,
e ho sentito dentro di me
una grande energia come se lui,
come se la sua energia, fossero
entrati dentro di me.
Ho chiaro davanti agli occhi cosa fare:
dedicare la mia vita ai giovani,
andare ovunque a raccontare,
attraverso la nostra storia,
il valore della vita.
E quella notte, alle tre, ho scritto
una lunga lettera,
dedicata ad Emanuele,
nella quale gli facevo una promessa,
che avrei creato un'associazione
per aiutare i giovani.
Ed è così che nasce, dopo pochi giorni,
la fondazione EMA,
che sta per Emanuele, Pesciolino Rosso.
E da allora ho cominciato ad andare in una scuola, un'altra, quell'altra.
Ho tenuto 973 incontri,
in 3 anni e mezzo, in tutta Italia.
Sono andato da Merano fino a Canicattì.
Ma io sono andato davvero a Canicattì,
non è un modo di dire.
E' una città bellissima, in provincia di
Agrigento, con 35 mila abitanti.
Siamo passati da Scampìa,
siamo andati a Marano di Napoli,
siamo andati gratuitamente in ogni scuola
dove ci hanno chiamato,
abbiamo pubblicato 5 libri
sul rapporto genitori figli,
sul rapporto scuola, genitori, figli,
sul valore della vita.
E un regista, un giorno, l'anno scorso,
viene da me. Un regista romano
di opere teatrali, anche attore,
mi dice: "Leggi questo."
Ha scritto un'opera teatrale intitolata
"Lasciami volare",
come il libro in cui
è contenuta la lettera.
"Lasciami volare"
è già andata in scena in sei teatri.
Chissà, il mio sogno, un giorno,
portarlo anche dentro
in questo bellissimo teatro.
Quando vado nelle scuole
parlo ai giovani.
Ogni volta che abbraccio un giovane
è come se abbracciassi il mio Emanuele.
Ai giovani, sì,
parlo anche delle dipendenze,
ma soprattutto gli dico
"Sì, forse fate anche
l'istinto vostro di buttarvi via
di bere, di farvi le canne
perché magari
vi fa schifo questo mondo,
ci sono cose storte.
Però gli dico:
"Va bene, buttatevi in quel mondo
ma ricordatevi che un giorno
vi sputeranno addosso,
vi pisceranno addosso e
dovrete mettere giù la testa,
non sapete che vi vogliono controllare?
Mettetevi in gioco per cambiare le cose,
quello dovete fare,
cercare un sogno.
Ed è meraviglioso, l'altro giorno,
proprio tre giorni fa,
ero a Milano; alla fine dell'incontro
è arrivato un ragazzo di 18 anni,
mi ha abbracciato,
è scoppiato in un pianto.
Mi dice: "Gian Pietro aiutami,
Io non ho più un sogno;
mi faccio le canne, ho cominciato
a farmi roba pesante,
proprio la settimana scorsa.
Io voglio uscirne, aiutami;
aiutami a trovare un sogno.
Mi hai fatto capire che,
se mi butto in quel mondo,
in quella strada,
io non ce la farò mai."
Ed è meraviglioso questo, sentire
ragazzi che ti dicono all'orecchio:
"Mi hai cambiato la vita.
Mi hai salvato la vita".
Io li chiamo i piccoli
miracoli di Emanuele.
Quando vado a parlare con i genitori,
ecco ai genitori dico:
"Impariamo davvero a
non giudicare solo i nostri figli.
Non dobbiamo essere i loro carabinieri
ma dobbiamo essere i loro guerrieri."
E dico ai ragazzi, eccoli qui,
eravamo a Auronzo di Cadore,
ai ragazzi di fare la rivoluzione RAP.
Cos'è la rivoluzione RAP?
R sta per ringraziare.
Ringraziare ogni giorno
per quello che abbiamo
e non ritenere tutto scontato.
A, saper aiutare gli altri.
C'è qualcosa di meraviglioso nell'amore,
nel donarsi,
nell'aiutare chi è più sfortunato di noi;
non guardiamo sempre
i nostri singoli problemi.
E P vuol dire prepararsi.
Prepararsi per cambiare il mondo,
amare, innamorarsi della cultura,
perché sarà la cultura
che li rende liberi.
Ma la P, il mio RAP ha due P,
vuol dire anche perdonare.
Il perdono ci libera dal rancore
che soffoca la nostra capacità
di liberare amore.
Sapete cosa fa chi non perdona se stesso?
È come se si crogiolasse dentro nei
propri sensi di colpa, nel dolore
e...rimane immobile, non si muove più.
Bisogna liberarsi.
Guardare avanti.
Io mi sforzo ogni giorno di perdonare, di
perdonare anche me stesso,
perché l'unica cosa che non possiamo
cambiare è il nostro passato.
E allora, lo dice anche
un'università americana,
Fred Laskin della Stanford University,
insegna la materia del perdono,
dice: "Do good rather than feel bad",
"Fai del bene piuttosto che stare male".
Ecco, lo dico anch'io.
L'unico modo per guarire
dal male
è davvero quello di donarsi,
di aiutare gli altri.
Per cui qualsiasi cosa voi abbiate dentro,
qualsiasi senso di colpa,
qualsiasi dolore,
qualsiasi frustrazione per aver sbagliato,
rialzatevi, guardate avanti,
non rimandate anche questo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)